hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Gotham episode 8 video so we
actually got some really cool stuff we
got black masks
who's this guy here a few minor changes
to the character and we got a giant hush
name-drop really it ended up turning
into like a backdoor Fight Club episode
for both Bruce and for Gordon both of
them made this really big sweeping
declaration that was actually pretty
exciting I think episode 10 is gonna be
the actual mid-season finale but I'll
keep you guys posted if they change
things so careful for spoilers from
episode 8 if you're not cut up yet but
starting with top five moments number
five the penguin gets a seat at the
table just a whole lot of apples and
torture apples and torture what a great
snack their first interaction is
actually a nice twist on the classic
Star Wars obi-wan Kenobi Darth Vader
scene now I am the master of evil
although technically that'd be a Marvel
reference DC has the secret society of
super villains the whole scene is just
about setting terms between Moroney and
Falcone but no one knows that the
penguin is secretly informing for
Falcone they teased it later in the
episode but he's probably gonna find out
who Liza is Falcone does seem like a
pretty clever guy but it seems like
based on the interactions we've seen
with him he has no idea that Liza's
informing to fish Mooney did anyone else
get a little creepy vibe when fish
Mooney said that she's basically all
three things for him
housekeeper mother and lover I like the
way they juxtaposed that relationship
with penguins mother although she's more
of a mentor to him more than he realizes
probably don't you just totally love how
wicked Carol Kane was in this episode at
first glance she seems kind of silly but
then you listen to her story about how
she got rid of her friend by informing
the secret police about her father that
means he either got thrown in a
concentration camp thrown into jail
thrown into gulag depending on where
they came from
number four Bruce has to go to private
school now just like all the other
billionaire orphans the school itself
has actually a pretty spectacular
location like it looked amazing I wish
my school looked like that when I was a
little kid this is where we get our
first giant hush name-drop he's the kid
that Bruce ends up beating up or trying
to beat up at school before Alfred gives
him the business for those that don't
know hush was a huge character in the
comics it's actually the title of the
comic book he appeared in like the
biggest comic book he appeared in you
should definitely check it out if you
haven't read it yet it's just called
Batman hush
if you've read Quarter the owls it
remind
me a little bit of his adversary in that
book although the story is vastly
different it's like the Bruce
wayne/batman
facing a twisted version of himself
number three
Alfred agrees to Train Bruce let the
ninja training begin although
technically alfred was raf so he'd be
treating him more in like hand-to-hand
combat i think this is gonna be a slight
retcon of the Christopher Nolan Batman
origin story we didn't really know
anything about Christian Bale's young
Bruce Wayne's ability to fight it just
imply that he gets in a lot of fights at
school I just love how Shaun Pertwee's
face looks and that scene where he says
yes yes I will there's just like a
slight devilish twinkle in his eye we
got a little taste of badass Alfred in
the last episode so I'm really hoping
that there's some sort of break in or we
actually get to see Alfred throw down
for real Sean Pertwee isn't a giant
person but that's why I think it'll be
so much fun to watch him kick someone's
butt and we would expect nothing less
from the son of the third doctor for
those who don't know Sean Pertwee is the
son of John Pertwee he was the third
doctor on Doctor Who that doctor was
known for doing a lot of karate chopping
like a lot of hand-to-hand combat karate
moves so it's just a fun Easter Egg for
Doctor Who - for fans of that number -
no one appreciates nygma I sense a dam
of rage that's going to burst pretty
soon and nygma is gonna snap I love that
Cory Michael's getting more since he's a
great actor and he's great as nygma I
love how excruciatingly in detail his
coroner's report started to get before
he was interrupted what the show's
starting to apply is is that he has like
so much more to offer them in terms of
intellect and insight and no one wants
to listen to him or give him the time of
day
I think Bullock appreciates him a little
bit as much as he has to and the captain
understands that he has value but I feel
like we're gonna keep seeing scenes
where he gets kicked in the pants and
eventually he's just gonna get tired of
it and do something crazy like go full
on Riddler even if he's not wearing a
crazy question mark suit if you look at
some of the promo for the show he's
actually wearing a pinstripe suit like
really subtle pinstripes so I think the
nicer his suits get like the more
outlandish his suits get the crazier
he's gonna get so just watch out for
that watch what he wears
and my number one moment meet black mask
so small twist on the character it's
Richard C onus on the show in the comics
the first version of the black mask was
named Roman sea
I think they just changed the name to
avoid confusion because on the show
they're already calling carmine Falcone
the Roman for all intents and purposes
though just view him as the black mask
the origin story gets a slight tweak in
the comics he was a crime boss who came
from a wealthy family but if you want to
talk about Joker Easter eggs we haven't
seen one a little while
in the comics black mask lost his
company before he became black mask
because of a face paint that ended up
being super toxic he was like a cosmetic
company owner in the new 52 universe
like in the more recent comics he
appears as an inmate under Jeremiah
Arkham in Arkham Asylum during forever
evil he was even part of the secret
society of super villains his mask gives
him some hypnosis powers and his gang
known as the false face society they all
wear masks too that also give them
low-level hypnotic powers really one of
the most fun things wasn't so much the
fight it was actually the speech he gave
about the freedom that masks give you
it's really foreshadowing for his future
as a crime boss as black mask and for
Batman wearing the cape and cowl but
what he said is it masks speak the truth
inside you they free your soul very
poetic way to introduce a brand new
super villain on Gotham I really love
that the show is rolling out new super
villains like every week and in case you
were confused about that scene with fish
Mooney and the older lady singing
that really was her mother she was lying
about that like her mother wasn't dead
like a dead hooker I didn't recognize
the actress that was playing that older
woman I think she might have been
someone from the classic series I know
everyone is really hoping that Adam West
gets a cameo on the show at some point
like his great ghost like they do with
Batman the Animated Series let me know
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and if Adam West ever did get a
cameo on the show who would you want him
to play and would you want to play a
villain or like a hero why you guys
think about that here's some of the
other Easter eggs that I spotted in the
episode that I didn't mention already
Anders Academy the private school they
make Bruce co2 is actually named after a
classic Golden Age DC artist named Al
Anders I didn't mention it when I was
talking about hush
but eventually hush ends up recruiting
the Riddler during his first scheme to
go after Batman like the first time he
appeared in the comics he was working
with the Riddler
Bruce is easily like eight years away
from putting the cowl on so I don't
think they'd let another kid turned into
hush before that just laying some ground
where
laying some groundwork just in case they
get season 20 overall I gave the episode
of solid beat just for doing a good job
of mirroring each of the storylines you
know this big well of Rage just building
up in all the characters and teasing the
fact that all the monsters are coming
out of the woodwork Gotham has had a
really tall order like they have all
these Batman villains like an ocean of
Batman villains that they have to deal
with even a more mature show like arrow
takes its time introducing new big comic
book characters so Gotham really is
going out on a limb but Fox is rolling
hard that it's gonna do well and so far
it's actually been pretty successful
from a ratings perspective but their
Gamble has paid off but the show looks
absolutely beautiful regardless of what
you think about the stories I will say
that's probably one of its biggest
strengths is just this visual style one
thing I do think that they could do a
little bit better is just take a page
from arrows stunt Department I feel like
their fight choreography could use a lot
of work I mean Gordon isn't gonna be
doing parkour anytime soon but he was in
the military so we know he's a good
fighter if you don't watch arrow there's
this guy named James Bamford who does
their fight choreography he's totally
amazing
whenever you see Stephen Amell doing
parkour in unison with Colton Haynes all
over the place that's thanks to the
fight coordinator it's like
choreographing a really grand dance with
a lot of punching so big things to look
forward to next week we're getting our
Harvey Dent episode so be sure to
subscribe to get it I'll post it right
after the episode airs it's gonna be
Gordon teaming up with him to take care
of the Wayne murder case they're gonna
try and close it down I don't expect
them to but that's what the episodes
gonna center around in the meantime if
you haven't seen it you can click here
for my episode 7 video and you can click
here for my episode 6 video thank you so
much for watching so I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
you